pourquoi
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat dans un
instant vous allez pouvoir suivre
l'examen du projet de loi relatif aux
soins psychiatriques à mes côtés pour en
parler valérie létard sénatrice
centriste du nord et ancien secrétaire
d'état à bonjour alors parmi les
principales dispositions de ce texte est
bien c'est la création de soins
ambulatoires sans consentement
cette disposition avait été supprimée en
commission hier elle est revenue en
séance par le biais d'un amendement du
sénateur alain milon
est-ce que ça va un compromis acceptable
ce qui s'est passé hier alors tout à
fait il y a eu effectivement des débats
compliqués en commission des affaires
sociales qui ont abouti à ce que des
premières positions qui ont été prises
au sein de cette commission qui visait à
supprimer effectivement ses soins
ambulatoires sans consentement est bien
finissent par ne pas être voté par la
commission des affaires sociales alors
c'est très compliqué mais enfin le
résultat est celui là il fallait en
séance voir comment sortir de cela
et quelle était la position que nous
pouvions prendre tous ensemble qui tire
ce texte vers le haut et qui permet
d'encadrer la possibilité de faire des
soins ambulatoires sans consentement
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
et monsieur milan qui avait voté ces
fameux amendement de suppression comme
je les avais voté a proposé un
amendement qui recadrait un peu les
choses et qui permettait donc de bien
clarifier ce que pourraient être ses
soins ambulatoire c'est-à-dire une
alternative à l'hospitalisation complète
en établissement psychiatrique soit à
domicile soit en soins qu'ils soient
faits en établissement mais sur des
rendez vous réguliers fait dans cet
établissement en proposant que
l'établissement de santé référent et
donc le médecin référent établissent un
programme de soins alors un programme de
soi ça veut dire que pour chaque
personne qui pourrait partir en soins
ambulatoires sans consentement
il y est bien sûr un médecin qui définit
ce qu'elle est l'accompagnement idéal
est bien évidemment de le faire
selon les modalités adaptées et voulue
par le médecin psychiatre
alors moi j'ai posé une question hier
parce qu'il me semble que cet amendement
proposé par monsieur milon encadrent
beaucoup mieux les règles qui vont régir
tous là à une condition que j'ai
exprimée hier c'est que l'on nous
clarifie quels seront les moyens mis en
place
là justement quelle est la réponse du
gouvernement sur les moyens alors j'ai
demandé effectivement à ce qu'on nous
dise comment dans le prochain budget
donc pour 2012 on nous donnera les
moyens main et donc financiers pour
faire en sorte que les établissements de
référence puisse avoir les infirmières
psychiatriques par exemple pour
accompagner à domicile donc là dessus ça
veut dire qu'il faut augmenter les
effectifs ont en tout cas de donner la
possibilité à des infirmières qui sont
dans les établissements de référence est
bien d'aller à domicile et de suivre le
programme de soins prescrits par le
médecin
alors pour ce faire ça veut dire qu' il
faudra que madame berra et c'est ce
qu'elle nous a proposé hier soit en
mesure et elle l'a dit de nous rassurer
sur le fait que pour chaque personne qui
aura des soins ambulatoire c'est-à-dire
des soins qu'ils soient portés à
l'extérieur de l'établissement ou dans
l'établissement mais à temps partiel
entre guillemets et bien il y à chaque
fois un référent un professionnel qui
soit chargée de son accompagnement pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de personnes qu'ils
soient sans suivi car effectivement il y
aura là un vrai sujet ce sont des
malades qui ont besoin d'être pris en
charge de façon qualitative et donc il
faudra bien sûr former des infirmières
psychiatriques suffisant parce qu'on en
aura pas assez ça veut dire qu'il faudra
augmenter forcément ou organiser le
quota des professionnels de ces
établissements pour qu'il puisse aller à
domicile et en même temps continue à
bien fonctionner dans les établissements
madame sénateur va le rendez vous rendez
vous donc à l'examen budgétaire prochain
et elle s'est engagée à ce que
effectivement face à chaque personne à
accompagner il y est bien un référent
qui accompagne ce parcours de soin
sénateurs ont pourtant déploré en fait
l'absence d'un grand plan de santé
mentale
don de la france a besoin qu'est ce que
vous en pensez mais je pense que tout le
monde le partage sur tous les bancs du
sénat à droite comme à gauche que à
partir du moment où un texte nous est
proposé c'est vrai qu'il est
insatisfaisant c'est vrai que c'est un
premier rendez-vous qui malheureusement
n'est pas suffisamment équilibré parce
qu'il ne repense pas le système dans sa
globalité
mais à partir du moment où on nous
présente un texte eh bien nous essayons
de l'adapter au mieux des intérêts des
personnes à prendre en charge et avec
aussi un contexte médecins mais aussi
système judiciaire c'est à dire qu'il
nous faut des juges il ya toute une
procédure à suivre
qu'ils soient aussi organisé pour
pouvoir prendre en charge cette réforme
cette nouvelle possibilité dont les
meilleures conditions possibles c'est le
travail qu'on essaye de faire
c'est vrai c'est pas suffisant il nous
faudra un grand axe de santé mentale à
l'avenir c'est une première pierre
encore une fois un satisfaisant parce
que pas globale mais à nous de la cadrer
et de demander les éléments de précision
suffisant pour être sûr que pour cette
partie des soins ambulatoires sans
consentement est bien tout soit abordé
les moyens souhaite organiser pour que
ça se passe dans la plus grande sécurité
pour les patients et leur environnement
valérie létard merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je vous laisse regagné
l'hémicycle du sénat
à suivre donc la suite de l'examen de ce
projet de loi relatif aux soins
psychiatriques très bonne séance à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale relatif aux droits
et à la protection des personnes faisant
l'objet de soins psychiatriques et aux
modalités de leur prise en charge
dans la discussion des articles nous
sommes parvenus à l'amendement numéro
112 au sein de l'article 1er quarante et
un amendement font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement 112
et présenté l'amendement 112
ah pardon alors on distribue
madame de mantas lomagne le mani
alors la 112 il est présenté par
monsieur mène dans la ministre dans la
mesure où le présent projet de loi
s'inscrit dans une perspective
sécuritaire qui est un amalgame et
délinquance et maladie mentale la place
du juge judiciaire est prépondérante
dans le cadre de nos différents
amendements qui consacre la
judiciarisation de l'ensemble la
procédure visant à établir des soins
psychiatriques sans consentement
nous accordons davantage de pouvoirs au
juge l'objectif est de rééquilibrer ce
texte dans le sens d'une protection
accrue des droits des malades
autrement dit il s'agit de se concentrer
sur l'aspect sanitaire plutôt que de
focaliser sur l'argument spécieux ayant
trait au maintien de l'ordre public
en somme comme dans nombreux autres
domaines le juge se voit conférer un
rôle croissant est imminent au moment où
les projets de lois sécuritaires sont
légion il devient un véritable garde la
liberté analysant la nécessité et la
proportionnalité de la mesure qui lui
est donnée à examiner aujourd'hui le
juge des libertés la détention est
littéralement submergé par les dossiers
qui a vu son bureau
la récente réforme de la garde à vue
n'est pas de nature à inverser la
tendance et devrait au contraire
exacerbé ce phénomène en outre la
répartition des juges de la liberté la
détention sur le territoire et
particulièrement inégale en l'état
l'application du volet juridique de la
présente réforme risquerait d'être
problématique
in fine est cela nuirait à la protection
des droits du malade et pourrait
lourdement pesé sur son traitement
sanitaire
comme le gouvernement la majorité se
font régulièrement les champs du
pragmatisme
nous espérons qu'ils seront sensibles à
notre amendement qui vise à garantir une
meilleure organisation de la justice par
conséquence nous demandons à ce que le
juge des libertés et de la détention
soient remplacés dans l'ensemble du
projet de loi par le président du
tribunal de grande instance ou son
délégué par cet intermédiaire le
président du tribunal de grande instance
aura la possibilité d'assumer lui-même
les pouvoirs qui lui incombent en vertu
de ce projet de loi vous de les déléguer
à un ou plusieurs juges
merci chers collègues
l'amendement numéro 9 est présentée par
monsieur le surf au nom de la commission
des lois
ministre sur collègues cet amendement
prévoit la possibilité pour le juge des
libertés et de la détention de
transformer une hospitalisation complète
en soin ambulatoire dans le cadre d'un
recours facultatif
en effet les députés ont finalement
souhaité ne pas doter le jld d'une telle
possibilité
après avoir pris une position contraire
en commission l'amendement reprend le
dispositif qui avait été adopté par la
commission de l'assemblée nationale et
qui figurait d'ailleurs dans le projet
de loi initial avant la lettre
rectificative
considérant qu'il permettrait aux juges
de moduler sa décision
il pourrait ainsi décider que la
personne ne nécessite plus
d'hospitalisation complète mais qu'elles
requièrent des soins ambulatoires
l'amendement est cohérent avec le fait
que le préfet se voit bien reconnaître
lui la possibilité d'apprécier les avis
médicaux et de ne pas les suivre au
regard des exigences liées à la sûreté
des personnes et à l'ordre public
pourquoi dans ces conditions le juge
tout autant généralistes que le préfet
ne pourrait-il pas se livrer à une telle
appréciation cohérent également avec le
fait que le projet de loi lui même
prévoit que le juge peut aussi les
saisies se prononcer sur les soins
ambulatoires sans consentement cohérent
avec le fait que d'une manière générale
le législateur a depuis longtemps
accordée au juge la possibilité de se
prononcer sur la nécessité de soins
toutefois s'il appartient au juge de se
prononcer sur le principe des soins
c'est toujours aux médecins bien sûr on
assurait la mise en oeuvre et d'en
définir le contenu
c'est pourquoi l'amendement précise que
lorsque le juge ordonne la mainlevée de
la mesure d'hospitalisation complète en
lui substituant des soins ambulatoires
sous contrainte sa décision prend effet
dans un délai maximal de 24 heures
pendant lequel un protocole de soins est
établi par un psychiatre
il est précisé qu'à l'issue de ce délai
et en l'absence d'établissements de ce
ce protocole les soins sans consentement
prenne fin je rappelle aussi ce que je
disais en discussion générale
c'est-à-dire le fort risque
d'inconstitutionnalité du texte adopté
par l'assemblée nationale et je crains
qu'il ne s'agisse d'un euphémisme qui
prévoit effectivement qu'une décision de
main levée de l'hospitalisation complète
ne prendra effet qu'au bout de 48 heures
merci chez collègues l'amendement numéro
114 et présentée par monsieur le maine
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
il semble qu'il y ait accord entre nos
différentes sensibilités politiques sur
ces bases sur la définition du rôle du
juge qui est là pour contrôler la
validité de la procédure pour entendre
la personne retenue dans ce sens sans
consentement
la personne de confiance qu'elle aura
désigné ou son avocat
vous vérifiez que ne s'exerce pas sur
elle une coercition insupportable nous
pensons qu'il faut laisser faire le
corps médical dans l'esprit d'une
priorité aux soins le juge ne peut en
rester à son contrôle
sans tirer les conclusions qui lui
paraissent les plus opportunes en accord
avec la priorité ci dessus évoqués dans
ce qui nous est proposé aujourd'hui la
personne et sous la contrainte d'avis ou
décision qui ne concerne pas
exclusivement son état santé
c'est encore le souci sécurité a scandé
à chaque partie du projet de loi qui
nous est soumis et que nous dénonçons
puis le débat général
c'est pourquoi avec cet amendement nous
appelons retour à la version initiale du
projet de loi telle qu'elle avait été
soumise en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale d'où notre
amendement
merci chers collègues l'amendement 458
rectifier et présenté par madame
escoffier merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre
c'est un cet amendement a le même objet
que celui qui vient d'être exposé par
nora porter et par les différents
intervenants
nous estimons nous aussi que le juge des
libertés et de la détention doit pouvoir
transformer une hospitalisation complète
en soins ambulatoires
que ce soit dans le cadre du recours
facultatif ou celui du recours
obligatoire
je rejoins donc les arguments qui ont
été exposés par notre rapporteur et nos
collègues sur l'effectivité du pouvoir
de contrôle du juge
en ayant pour seule alternative la levée
ou le maintien de l'hospitalisation il
est à craindre que ce contrôle se résume
à une simple confirmation systématique
des avis médicaux ne disposant pas de
statut propre étant régulièrement montré
du droit au gré de l'actualité en
particulier dans les cas de récidive
pénale
le juge des libertés et de la détention
aura tendance au moindre doute a ordonné
le maintien
faute de temps de moyens et sous la
pression continue il ne pourra donc
jouer pleinement son rôle de garant des
libertés individuelles
il faut permettre aux juges de se
dégager de l'amalgamme qui conduit à
privilégier pour éviter tout risque
l'enfermement plutôt que
l'accompagnement l'amendement de notre
réponse de notre rapporteur répond à ces
préoccupations comme le nôtre mais sa
rédaction ne nous satisfait pas
pleinement monsieur le rapporteur et
j'en suis un petit peu navré votre vous
proposait en effet que la décision du
juge prenne effet dans un délai maximal
de 24 heures pour permettre
l'élaboration d'un protocole de soin ou
d'un programme de soins
cet effet différé nous interroge regard
du droit et sur le plan constitutionnel
comme l'avait indiqué nous lui préférons
riom une autre rédaction qui pourrait
être celle là lorsque le juge ordonne la
mainlevée de la mesure d'hospitalisation
complète en le substituant des soins en
ambulatoire
un protocole de soin est établie en
l'absence d'établissement d'un tel
protocole dans les 48 heures les soins
sans consentement prenne fin c'est une
petite nuance semble-t-il mais qui fait
une différence et nous aurions souhaité
peut-être monsieur le rapporteur que
vous puissiez vous rallier à notre
proposition
mais si chers collègues nous enchaînons
sur le 459 rectifié madame escoffier
alors nous revenons là encore et
toujours sur la procédure renforcer
appliquée aux malades ayant fait l'objet
d'une décision de justice déclarant leur
irresponsabilité pénale ou séjourner en
unité pour malades difficiles les
alinéas 71 à 76 prévoit en effet le
recours à un collège de soignants et à
deux expertises avant toute décision du
juge des libertés et de la détention les
concernant comme nous l'avons déjà dit
au cours des débats d'hier en défendant
d'autres amendements les antécédents
d'un patient doivent certes a mené à une
meilleure vigilance et un meilleur suivi
mais que des psychiatres mobilisés et on
a vu le nombre d'examens qui était
préconisé dans un contexte marqué par
l'insuffisance des moyens dévolus à la
santé en particulier à la psychiatrie et
nous avons été nombreux là aussi à le
souligner la saisine du juge doit être
accompagnée d'un avis conjoint rendu par
deux psychiatres et celui ci a toujours
la possibilité d'ordonner une expertise
complémentaire
faisons donc confiance en la capacité de
ces professionnels à évaluer les
situations à s'entourer de plusieurs
avis si nécessaire pour les cas les plus
difficiles
le droit à l'oubli introduit par nos
collègues députés est sans doute une
avancée par rapport au texte initial
encore que le délai à compter duquel il
s'applique n'est pas précisé mais il ne
suffit pas à dissiper notre malaise
devant un texte qui privilégie un point
de vue sécuritaire alimentant l'amalgamé
entre maladies mentales et délinquance
violence et des heureux et dangerosité
nous l'avons dit une réforme
convaincante se devait bien sûr de
prendre en compte des impératifs de
sécurité mais nous aurions souhaité
qu'elle soit davantage tourné vers la
prise en charge du patient
quoi qu'il en soit nous estimons que
chacun a droit à ce que l'appréciation
de son cas se fasse sur la seule base de
son état actuel et des nécessités de son
traitement
tel n'est pas le cas dans la procédure
proposée c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposons de le supprimer
merci chers collègues bien
le 121 et présentée par monsieur le
maine ainsi le président la ministre au
bout de cet amendement permettez moi de
prendre en référence la plume de serge
portelli
dans son dernier livre jugé je cite si
la justice est une exigence sociale si
elle est nécessairement infiltré des
contraintes du pouvoir
elle peut aujourd'hui acquérir une
légitimité nouvelle susceptible d'en
changer la nature elle-même cette
légitimité tient au nouveau assignée à
toutes les justices du monde depuis les
abominations de la dernière guerre
mondiale
la sauvegarde de la liberté cette
mission fondatrice c'est le devoir du
moindre petit juge l'autre socle est
tout simplement l'humanité fondée sur
tout ce que les sciences humaines
nous on appris de l'homme depuis
quelques siècles
c'est ce savoir qui seule permet de
comprendre les hommes et leurs actes
mais aussi d' humaniser l'ensemble du
fonctionnement d'un appareil toujours
tentés par la froideur la rapidité la
rentabilité au détriment de l'essentiel
l'homme fin de citation c'est pourquoi
le juge va être à même en toute
indépendance de convoquer de convoquer
sans que cela fut considéré exceptionnel
les expertise lui permettant d'éclairer
sa décision elle ne pas être tributaire
de l'unique avis du collège mentionnée à
l'article l 3213 tiré neuf tel que cela
est prévu de ce projet de loi c'est le
sens de cet amendement merci chers
collègues
l'amendement et 485 qui est présenté par
le rapporteur au nom de la commission
des lois les affaires sociales ce
président bien alors la procédure du
collège ne doit toucher que les
personnes qui font l'objet d'une
hospitalisation
sur décision du préfet et non celles qui
le sont à la demande d'un tiers ou en
cas de péril imminent
cette précision figure déjà pour les
personnes ayant séjourné en umd
c'est pourquoi seules celles qui sont ré
hospitalisé sur décision du préfet font
l'objet de la procédure particulière du
collège et de deux expertises
merci monsieur rapporteur l'amendement
123 et présentée par monsieur le maine
ça ferait cours il s'agit uniquement
demande la suppression de la ligne à 74
on vise le dépassement des dispositions
relatives à la procédure particulière
applicable aux personnes ayant séjourné
à 1 unité de malades difficiles ou ayant
fait l'objet d'une déclaration
d'irresponsabilité pénale
merci l'amendement numéro 10 s'est
présentée alors là par monsieur sert au
nom de la commission des lois de
précision qui concerne le droit à
l'oubli instauré par les députés qui
concerne donc les personnes ayant
séjourné en umd unité pour malades
difficiles où ils ont fait l'objet d'une
hospitalisation d'office judiciaire il
s'agissait de préciser que le point de
départ de la période à l'issue de
laquelle s'exercera le droit à l'oubli
est nécessairement la fin des
hospitalisations des personnes
concernées cependant je vais retirer cet
amendement au bénéfice d'un amendement
suivant qui reprennent le dispositif
proposé par cet amendement et ajoute le
délai de dix ans à l'issue duquel
effectivement cette ce droit à l'oubli
pourra s'établir
j'avoue que la commission des lois avait
elle même réfléchit s'était elle-même
interrogé sur le point de savoir si le
fait de laisser aux décrets fixé le
délai ne crée pas une sorte d'
incompétence législatives et ne mettez
pas en cause donc la compétence du
législateur
je crois donc que les amendements
suivant apporte une heureuse réponse et
je retire la bande numéro 10 merci chers
collègues donc le 486 présentée par
monsieur laurin on ne la commission des
affaires sociales
cet amendement le président vise à
alléger le nombre d' expertise
nécessaire à la levée des mesures de
soins sans consentement imposé pour
certaines catégories de patients
ainsi seule une expertise avec la vie du
collège devraient être recueillis par le
juge des libertés et de la détention
pour laver la mesure des soins contre 2
actuellement dans une volonté
d'allègement merci la nan deux
amendements identiques le 124 présentée
par monsieur pas sous le nom de l'ispan
décidément merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement est en relation avec le
droit à l'oubli notion introduite par le
rapporteur à l'assemblée nationale
elle a trait aux antécédents
psychiatriques des personnes ayant été
déclaré pénalement irresponsable ou
ayant séjourné en unité pour malades
difficiles pour ces personnes il est
prévu une procédure renforcer l'examen
des propositions de modifications de
prise en charge ou de main levée de la
mesure de soins sans consentement
que ce soit devant juge ou devant le
préfet ainsi le droit à l'oubli
représente une avancée majeure qui vise
vous le savez a limité la stigmatisation
de ces personnes précédemment atteintes
de troubles psychiatriques
il se fonde également sur le postulat
qui a orienté la grande loi sur la
psychiatrie de 1838
selon lequel la personne victime de
troubles mentaux peut guérir mais
influence manifeste des travaux de
françois pinel et de gens détiennent
d'esquirol le présent projet de loi
revient sur ce paradigme et effectue un
retour en arrière dommageable et qui
aura des conséquences négatives sur les
personnes
naturellement nous ne contestons
aucunement le droit à l'oubli
en revanche nous souhaitons que le
législateur
fixe lui-même le délai à partir duquel
ce droit s'applique
rappelons que le législateur pourrait
être rappelé à l'ordre pour incompétence
négative
s'il ne déterminait pas lui-même ce
délai indirectement lié à une mesure
privative de liberté
d'autre part ce délai ne peut être
excessivement longs sous peine de porter
atteinte au principe de respect de la
vie privée constitue ciellement
constitutionnellement garanti par
l'article 2 de la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen d'ailleurs je
vous le rappelle le conseil
constitutionnel a réaffirmé à maintes
reprises le caractère constitutionnel de
ce droit notamment dans sa décision
numéro 2 milles 9 581 du 10 juin 2009
relative à la loi favorisant la
diffusion et la protection de la
création sur internet
par conséquent nous désirons précisé que
le délai fixé ne peut excéder dix années
ce délai nous apparaît équilibré
raisonnable est opportun
si monsieur genro le 301 tombe
nous en arrivons aux 125
il est présenté par madame china jules
le texte adopté par l'assemblée
nationale prévoit que lorsque le juge
des libertés et de la détention
ordonne la mainlevée d'une mesure
d'hospitalisation complète sa décision
peut être différée de 48 heures afin de
permettre au psychiatre de
l'établissement d'accueil d'établir en
le cas échéant un protocole de soins
pendant l'ensemble de cette procédure le
patient resterait en hospitalisation
complète ce qui entraverait l'exercice
de ces libertés fondamentales notamment
d'aller et venir et d'autres termes ce
dispositif reviendrait à maintenir en
hospitalisation complète une personne
dont le jld a estimé qu'elle devait être
remise en liberté
par conséquent ce en vertu de l'article
66 de la constitution qui dispose que
nul ne peut être arbitrairement détenus
ce dispositif en cours et un fort risque
d'inconstitutionnalité
il s'agit d'une remise en cause
explicite de la décision de l'autorité
judiciaire gardienne de la liberté
individuelle et d'une atteinte aux
libertés publiques
d'un point de vue juridique il paraît
donc opportun de supprimer la ligne à 77
comme dont le dispositif est très
probablement anticonstitutionnelle et
chaque plug l'amendement 58 rectifiée
présentée par un homme masqué surprise
cet amendement est un petit peu dans le
même esprit que le précédent en fait
nous nous souhaitons amendé l'alinéa 77
qui prévoit que la main levée décidée
par le juge de prendre effet dans un
délai de 48 heures nous considérons que
cette décision devrait avoir un effet
immédiat comme toutes les décisions de
justice d'ailleurs sauf à dire que celle
ci soit la sortie par le juge lui même
d'un délit en effet la mainlevée
prononcée par le juge des libertés après
que celui ci ait reçu l'avis d'un
collège d'experts
aussi rien ne justifie que la personne
jugée apte à réintégrer la vie en
société par des experts psychiatres et
par le juge soit maintenu contre son gré
au sein de l'hôpital psychiatrique
pendant un délai maximum de 48 heures
d'ailleurs cette privation de liberté
prolongée est d'autant plus inadmissible
qu'elle présente un risque pour le
patient
je m'explique on peut très bien imaginer
que durant cette période de 48 heures le
patient continuera de se voir imposer
des traitements et des soins
en définitive c'est sous couvert de
donner aux professionnels de santé le
temps nécessaire pour pouvoir établir un
protocole de soins protocole uniquement
destiné aux personnes soumis à des soins
ambulatoires pour les types de soins
prescrits
les lieux de leurs réalisations et leur
périodicité que cet article donne la
possibilité de reculer la prise d'effet
de la main levée à l'égard de tous les
patients et non pas ce cela seulement
qu'ils devront être soumis à des soins
psychiatriques sous forme ambulatoire
enfin cette disposition par est d'autant
plus scandaleuse qu'à l'heure où le
rapporteur du projet de loi à
l'assemblée nationale se félicite dans
la presse de la mise en place d'un
contrôle du
je des libertés au service du
renforcement des droits
ce dernier permettent néanmoins à
l'administration de différer dans le
temps la prise d'effet de la décision de
ce juge
merci chers collègues
l'amendement deux cent soixante deux
tombes
l'amendement 487 est présentée par
monsieur laurent au nom de la commission
des affaires sociales
il s'agit d'un amendement de cohérence
monsieur le président si l'amendement
132 et la coordination d'accord
amendement 135 même chose
l'amendement 59 et présentée par
monsieur fisher alors cet amendement
vise à supprimer la linea 83 et cette
année les alinéas que nous proposons de
supprimer prévoit que l' expertise
rendue par la vie de deux psychiatres
ouvre un nouveau délai de 14 jours au
plus avant que le juge des libertés ne
prononce sa décision alors ce délai est
cumulable avec celui prévu au
premièrement c'est à dire à la nuit
n'est à 80 et qui pose le principe de
l'intervention de ce même juge des
libertés avant que de soit écoulé un
délai maximum de 15 jours
il résulte de la juxtaposition de ces
deux alinéas qu'un patient pourrait être
hospitalisées contre son gré durant
quinze jours + 14 jours 29 jours maximum
et sans que le juge des libertés ne se
soit prononcé sur l'opportunité ou non
de lever de la mesure de soins sans
consentement imposé tout pas au patient
de fait le délai d'intervention de 15
jours posées par les juges du conseil
constitutionnel ait largement dépassé
puisque pouvant être doublée alors nous
nous opposons à cette disposition qui
aura pour conséquence de prolonger des
mesures de privation de liberté de
manière non conforme au principe d'une
intervention dans les plus brefs délais
du juge des libertés et c'est ce qui est
toujours recherché
alors nous considérons que cette
expertise doit donc être impérativement
être diligentée et réalisé dans un délai
n'excédant 14 jours
après que la mesure privative de liberté
est été prononcé d'où le bien fondé de
cet amendement merci chers collègues
nous avons trois amendements identiques
tout d'abord le 62 il est présenté par
madame la barre président l'objet de
notre amendement est d'obtenir une loi
qui soit applicable sur le terrain et
qui prenne en compte la nature
particulière des troubles dont sont
atteints de les personnes mentionnées
dans ce projet de loi si de nombreux
points posent problème dans leurs
applications
ce sont les modalités de l'audition par
le juge des libertés du malade
hospitalisé sans son consentement qui
nous semble plus aberrant avec la mise
en place de la télé audiences on
constate une totale méconnaissance de la
part du législateur
des cas qui peuvent être traitées dans
les hôpitaux psychiatriques
une fois de plus cette loi ce band à
traiter les maladies mentales comme des
maladies physiques il est difficile
d'imaginer un patient délirant
persécutés ou un mystique se plier à une
telle farce c'est à dire rentrer dans un
scénario qui l'obligerait à parler à une
caméra ou à discuter avec un écran au
delà des probables des problèmes
relatives à son application
ce dispositif pourrait produire des
effets négatifs sur le patient et sur
son état de santé
effectivement on peut prévoir les effets
anxiogènes corps à un tel dispositif sur
le patient car en plus de le sortir du
cadre dessous des soins cela le placera
dans une situation où la technique
prendra le pas sur l'humain ainsi nous
vous prions de reconsidérer les dégâts
que cela occasionnera sur la santé de
nos concitoyens et de remettre de
l'humain dans la médecine psychiatrique
tant au niveau des traitements que des
formalités administratives et
judiciaires
bien que nous soyons pas d'accord avec
les modalités d'intervention du juge des
libertés
nous nous devons de vous proposer des
solutions qui pensent qu'ils protégeront
le malade
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
proposons cet amendement de suppression
merci chers collègues l'amendement 138
des présenté par un hameau texier
président c'est cet amendement porte sur
la possibilité
deux recours à la visioconférence pour
organiser l'audience donc en effet
l'article l'animé à 94 dispose qu'une
fois que le directeur d'établissements
d'accueil s'est assuré de l'absence de
position du patient
le juge des libertés et de la détention
peut décider que l'audience se déroule
dans une salle d'audience reliés par un
moyenne télécommunications audiovisuel à
une salle située dans l'établissement à
titre liminaire il convient de rappeler
que la non comparution devant le juge
doit rester l'exception comme le
rappelle l'étude d'impact de janvier
ainsi le conseil d'état a estimé que la
seule nécessité de réduire les coûts et
les contraintes de services inhérents
transfèrement des patients devant le
juge des libertés et de la détention ne
pouvait justifier qu'il soit porté
atteinte aux droits de ces derniers de
comparaître personnellement en l'étude
d'impact précités prévoit le recours à
la visioconférence dans 75% des cas ce
qui est excessif est contraire à la
jurisprudence
développé par le conseil d'état en
l'espèce protectrice des droits du
patient en outre d'un point de vue
matériel la visioconférence rend le
dialogue entre le juge et le patient
difficile voire impossible
le recours à cette pratique peut
exacerber l'incompréhension l'attention
et in fine et peser directement sur la
décision du juge
en d'autres termes le jugement sur la
personne atteinte de troubles
psychiatriques pourrait être fortement
altérée par cette pratique porteuse de
quiproquos par ailleurs n'oublions pas
que l'objectif prioritaire dans le cadre
des soins psychiatriques sans
consentement devrait être la guérison du
malade et non le maintien de l'ordre
public option apparemment choisi par ce
gouvernement dont on peut dire qu'il est
excessivement sécuritaire
en le recours à la visioconférence peut
se révéler révélé malvenue inadaptée et
dangereux pour la santé des personnes
souffrant de troubles mentaux à titre
d'exemple certains des patients peuvent
être atteint de paranoïa et avoir un
rapport particulier des formes et avec
la vidéo et les caméras par conséquent
la pratique de la visioconférence peut
être en totale contradiction avec le
traitement sanitaire prévu par l'équipe
médicale elle pu nuire à la santé des
personnes victimes de troubles mentaux
un aggravant leur pathologie pour ces
motifs d'ordre à la fois curatif
juridiques matériels
nous proposons donc de supprimer le
recours à la visioconférence
merci chers collègues l'amendement 465
rectifier et présenté par madame
escoffier oui et si vous le permettez
monsieur président peut-être le 466
puisque monsieur desessard n'est pas
louis alors s'agissant de du 465
rectifier le nous proposons la
suppression comme mes collègues viennent
de le dire aussi de 2,2 cet alinéa et
parce que il concerne donc le recours à
la visioconférence
un recours qui s'il était accepté quand
viendrait à méconnaître tout simplement
la nature particulière des troubles
présenté par ses malades et leur
situation de détresse et d'instabilité
nous l'avons d'ailleurs déjà dit lors
d'examens d'autres textes
nous avons dit notre position à cette
pratique qui pose plus de problèmes
qu'elles ne résoud de celui qu'elle
n'apporte de solutions
la première des questions c'est celle du
dialogue entre le juge et le patient un
dialogue rendu impossible sinon
difficile
la seconde de questions c'est la place
de l'avocat lui-même ne pouvant se
trouver à la fois au tribunal et auprès
de son client il ne peut exercer sa
fonction dans de bonnes conditions
quoi qu'il en soit nous estimons que sa
place doit être très prioritairement
auprès du client
soyons réalistes le recours à la
visioconférence et dans cette matière
complexe encore très méconnu par les
juridictions qui elle même on aurait du
mal à réaliser c'est c
ces auditions celle effective et vctv
l'effectivité même du recours devant le
juge qui se trouve compromis
c'est donc pour cela que nous proposons
cette suppression amendement de repli
c'est l'amendement 466 qui propose au
lieu de recourir à la vidéo conférence
de de faire en sorte que l'audience
puisse se tenir dans une salle aménagée
à cet effet au sein de l'établissement
et donc sans dispositif de
visioconférence
cette pratique est utilisé dans d'autres
pays comme la belgique la suède les
pays-bas
elle pose certes la question des moyens
de l'hôpital mais elle a le mérite par
rapport à la visioconférence de garantir
un accès au juge et un véritable
dialogue puisqu'il y à un face à face
entre le l'une et l'autre des personnes
c'est aussi une manière de pallier des
difficultés en termes d'accompagnement
et de transfert des malades au tribunal
car il est vrai que les infirmières sont
là pour soigner les malades et non pour
attendre au tribunal merci chers
collègues le 279 rectifié tombe de 466
rectifié vient d'être présentée le 14
rectifiée présentée par monsieur sert au
nom de la commission des lois
oui à cet amendement reprend un certain
nombre de préoccupations qui viennent
d'être exprimées tant par madame oseo
texier que par madame escoffier il a 2
objets d'une part il prévoit que si une
salle d'audience a été spécialement
aménagé sur l'emprise de l'hôpital
psychiatrique pour assurer la clarté la
sécurité et la sincérité des débats et
permettre aux juges de statuer
publiquement celui ci peut statuer dans
cette salle cet aménagement spécial je
le rappelle peut-être sommaire
accessibilité pour le public
signalétique adaptée affichage du rôle à
l'entrée de la salle
mais il est essentiel pour que la salle
soit clairement identifié comme étant un
lieu de justice
d'autre part l'amendement n'interdit pas
mais ils encadrent le recours à la
visioconférence
en premier lieu il précise que la
visioconférence n'est possible que si
l'hôpital psychiatrique a spécialement
aménagée en son sein
une salle d'audience dans des conditions
que je viens d'évoquer autrement dit que
le juge soit physiquement présents dans
cette salle où qu'ils n'interviennent à
distance depuis le palais de justice
les exigences portant sur l'aménagement
des lieux doivent être identiques
en second lieu l'aménagement prévoit que
le jld ne pourrait décider que
l'audience se déroule par
visioconférence que si un avis médical a
attesté que l'état mental de la personne
n'y fait pas obstacle et que en
conséquence la personne est en capacité
d'exprimer son opposition à ce procédé
comme le prévoit le projet de loi cet
avis médical ne sera pas nécessairement
dédié il pourrait ainsi n'être qu'une
mention de la vie conjointe rendue par
deux psychiatres qui accompagne la
saisine du juge dans le cadre d'un
recours de plein droit
ce dispositif semble à la commission des
lois se justifier par le fait que non
seulement les personnes atteintes de
troubles mentaux pourrait être dans
l'incapacité de comprendre les enjeux et
le sens de la vision conférence mais pis
encore la présence d'un écran et d'une
caméra pourrait aggraver leurs troubles
dans le cas par exemple de personnes
schizophrènes ou paranoïaque
en outre si la visioconférence telle
qu'elle est pratiquée aujourd'hui
par exemple en matière pénale ne pose
pas de difficulté technique particulière
certains défauts mineurs légère
déformation de la voie et qu'aux
coupures décalage de son pourrait
prendre pour certains patients des
proportions considérables et alter l
échange avec le magistrat pour connaître
relativement bien l'univers carcéral
je connais effectivement la peur panique
que connaissent effectivement un certain
nombre de détenus ayant un le
discernement à tout le moins à l terrain
devant effectivement ce type de
dispositif il appartiendra ainsi au
médecin d'évaluer en fonction de l'état
du patient dans quelle mesure les
inconvénients de la visioconférence qui
ne permet pas un échange direct humains
entre le juge et de justiciables sont ou
non contrebalancée par ceux d'un
transport au palais de justice et d'une
présentation devant le juge qui peuvent
également constituer des expériences
stigmatisante voire traumatisante
surtout que l'on ce qu'est le cas
elles occasionneront généralement des
temps des trente relativement long merci
chers collègues l'amendement 63 ans est
présenté par madame david oui merci
monsieur le président il sera encore
question de visioconférence et à
entendre les différentes interventions
précédentes on voit bien que cette
mesure est loin d'être accepté de faire
l'unanimité
cet amendement 63 en ce qui nous
concerne est donc un amendement de repli
par rapport à celui que viennent
convient de vous présenter un instant
pour la suppression de l'alinéa 94 nous
sommes en effet très réservé c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire sur cette mesure dont
on voit bien qu'elle est destinée à
tenter d'effacer le caractère
irréalisable de ce projet de loi en
effet l'intervention du juge des
libertés à laquelle vous ne pouviez
d'hergé compte tenu de la décision
rendue par le conseil constitutionnel
serait ainsi rendu possible appliqué
dans des conditions normales cette
mesure devrait entraîner la création
massive de juge de libertés et
d'auxiliaires de justice mesure que vous
vous interdisez pour respecter une
doctrine de rigueur et ce ne sont pas
les promesses d'hier au soir de cette
nuit de madame la ministre en ce qui
concerne le plan santé qui est venu nous
rassurer ainsi vous avez eu l'idée d'une
telle audience oubliant que celle ci
faisait également naître des difficultés
financières importantes puisqu'il faudra
équiper pour le moins des établissements
psychiatriques en matériel nécessaire
mais surtout si nous sommes opposés à
cette mesure c'est que nous considérons
qu'elle peut parfois être inappropriés à
des personnes qui souffrent de
pathologies lourdes intégrant parfois
une dimension de persécution
l'expérience du rapporteur de la
commission des lois vient ont témoigné
nous considérons par ailleurs qu'il
n'est pas acceptable que l'on applique à
des personnes malades
un accès au droit dérogatoire du droit
commun à des fins économiques
il aurait sans doute été préférable que
l'on prévoit un mécanisme de déplacement
du juge des libertés au plus près des
malades ce qui aurait été plus juste au
regard de leurs
pathologie notre amendement pour des
raisons d'application de l'article 40 se
limite donc à prévoir que la télé
audiences ne peut être réalisé qu'avec
l'accord écrit du patient ce qui est à
la fois gage du respect de la volonté du
patient et mécanismes de preuves pour
les équipes soignantes six cercles à
haegen l'amendement numéro 15 est
présentée par monsieur lessard au nom de
la commission des lois qui constitue un
nouvel encadrement du recours à la
visioconférence
il prévoit que si le patient est assisté
par un avocat celui ci ne peut se tenir
qu auprès de l'intéressé il supprime
ainsi la faculté que le texte reconnaît
à l'avocat de se trouver auprès du
magistrat possibilité qui avait paru à
la commission des lois incompatibles
avec le contact humain qui doit
s'établir lors d'une audience entre un
avocat et son client
lorsque ce dernier souffre de troubles
mentaux je dois cependant à la réalité
de vous dire que c'est d'amendements qui
dans un premier temps avait été acceptée
par le conseil national des barreaux a
fait l'objet dans un deuxième temps de
sentiment de regret du conseil national
des barreaux qui estime que ce serait
mieux
bien sûr s'il y avait la proximité
immédiate entre l'avocat et son client
qui est en même temps un client est
impatient mais qu il faut peut-être
mieux laisser une certaine souplesse
donc j'attendrai effectivement avec
beaucoup d'intérêt mais comme d'habitude
la vie du couvert de mots elle le 16e
président poursuit donc
l'amendement numéro 16 au stade un
moment de coordination avec des
dispositions qui se trouve à l'article 3
je vous propose mes chers collègues de
le retirer
et si ces dispositions sont votés à
l'article 3 nous laisserons l'assemblée
nationale un peu de travail
supplémentaire en terme de coordination
le dise la 17è un amendement de
clarification merci l'amendement numéro
c'est tout 64 avec trois amendements
identiques
il est présenté par madame borvo cohen
seat merci monsieur le président donc on
revient toujours au conseil
constitutionnel qui a décidé de
de prévoir que le juge des libertés
gardien des droits fondamentaux
devraient intervenir avant l'expiration
d'un délai de 15 jours pour statuer sur
le bien fondé de la mesure
d'hospitalisation sans consentement
alors on a déjà évidemment dit que
c'était une intervention bien tardive
mais néanmoins laquelle vous a fait vous
avez été contrainte
vous n'en vouliez même pas et là
maintenant on est dans cette
configuration
or si je comprends bien la décision du
jld au bout de 15 jours vous fait peur
décision qui intervient il faut bien le
dire
après vérification expertise
psychiatrique de évidemment tant dans sa
forme que faire formulé sa décision par
le jld donc apparemment vous en méfiez
puisque il ya un recours qui est
possible bon le recours est toujours
possible évidemment de toute décision
mais recourent donc du procureur de la
république et ce recours est suspensif
s'allier en kung fu sa part du principe
que le jld et des psychiatres et le jld
quand même risque fortement de se
tromper et que par contre le procureur
de la république lui va savoir ce qu'il
en est de l'état pathologique de du
patient après une hospitalisation qui
aura duré qu'un jour je crois que ce
n'est pas acceptable et ce qui n'est
surtout pas acceptable c'est que le
recours soit suspensif
voilà parce qu'un recours est toujours
possible mais je crois qu'il est pas
absolument anormal que le procureur
puisse se décider que le recours est
suspensif ce qui est contraire à tout
principe parce que au fond
la justification de cela c'est quand
même qu'il ya eu un doute très fort sur
le fait que le jld sont en capacité de
prendre sa décision après l'avis des
psychiatres
bon donc cesser je trouve que c'est
absolument pas acceptable et ça me
paraît pas du tout être dans l'esprit
des la préconisation du conseil
constitutionnel si chers collègues
l'amendement 139 et présenté par madame
demontès c'est le président cet
amendement cherche à répondre à une de
nos préoccupations majeures à la lecture
de ce projet de loi sécuritaire et
stigmatisants à cette fin il vise la
suppression des alinéas 97 et 98 de
l'article 20 rappelons l'objet de nos
griefs l'alinéa 97 prévoit que le
procureur puisse demander soit deux fils
soit à la roquette du directeur
d'établissement du préfet que l'appel
relatifs à la décision de main levée
d'une mesure de soins psychiatriques
sans consentement par hospitalisation
complète prononcée par le juge des
libertés et de la détention soit
suspensif
le premier président de la cour d'appel
décide alors s'il ya lieu de suivre la
demande du procureur il statue par une
ordonnance motivée rendu
contradictoirement qui n'est pas
susceptible de recours
autrement dit en l'état actuel du texte
le représentant de l'état et le
directeur d'établissement disposerait
d'un pouvoir d'appel par voie
d'injonction au procureur ce mécanisme
traduisant parfaitement la défiance du
gouvernement à l'encontre de ces
magistrats permettrait un contrôle
indirect des décisions rendues par le
juge des libertés et de la détention
adopter un tel année à serait donc
historique est-ce que vous en mesurer la
portée
une autorité administrative pourrait
effectuer des injonctions aux procureurs
soyons sérieux une telle disposition
créerait un précédent particulièrement
dangereux aucun texte en vigueur ne
prévoit la possibilité pour une autorité
administrative d'adresser une demande au
parquet dans le cadre d'un appel d'une
ordonnance du jld
l'introduction d'un tel pouvoir
d'injonction de l'exécutif sur
l'autorité
judiciaire sort est une atteinte au
principe de séparation des pouvoirs
principe ordonnateur de notre république
constitutionnellement garanti par
l'article 16 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen ainsi
nous aimerions rappeler au gouvernement
qui n'a qu'une considération minimes
pour ces magistrats que l'autorité
judiciaire n'est pas au service de
l'état soumis à la hiérarchie du préfet
plutôt que de remettre systématiquement
en cause le rôle et les décisions de
l'autorité judiciaire
parent pauvre de notre démocratie le
président de la république devrait
respecter ses prérogatives
issu de l'article 64 de la constitution
et bien s'affirmer comme le garant de
son indépendance en outre de manière
générale nous nous opposons au caractère
suspensif de l'appel qui peut être formé
par leur procureur il s'agit là de la
linea 98 en effet pendant l'ensemble de
la procédure précédemment décrites le
patient demeure en hospitalisation
complète
en d'autres termes alors que le jld
aurait prononcé une main levée de la
mesure de soins sans consentement
prenant la forme d'une hospitalisation
complète après avoir mené une analyse du
dossier une investigation approfondie le
patient pourrait néanmoins rester
enfermé dans un hôpital psychiatrique
ce dispositif en cours est un fort
risque d'anti d'inconstitutionnalité
dès lors qu'il reviendrait à maintenir
en hospitalisation complète pendant une
durée allant jusqu'à 14 jours une
personne dont le juge a estimé qu'elle
devait être remise en liberté
par conséquent cette disposition serait
une remise en cause explicite de la
décision de l'autorité judiciaire et des
libertés publiques
en revanche elle sort est la
matérialisation du postulat qui sous
tend ce projet de loi à savoir que la
ville personnes victimes de troubles
mentaux est nécessairement une menace
pour la société pour l'ordre public
eu égard à ces remarques d'ordre
juridique politique et philosophique
particulièrement lourde de sens et de
conséquences
nous retirons la suppression des alinéas
97 et 98 de l'article premier véritable
atteinte aux fondements de notre
démocratie
la gamme l'amendement 467 rectifier et
présenté par madame escoffier madame la
ministre je vais je ne reprendrai pas
les arguments qui viennent d'être
développées par mes deux les deux
oratrice précédente
donc nous proposons nous aussi la
suppression des alinéas 97 et 98 qui
prévoit la possibilité pour le directeur
de l'établissement où le préfet de
demander au procureur de la république
de saisir le premier président de la
cour d'appel afin que le recours à
l'encontre de la décision du juge des
libertés et de la détention soit
suspensif
quand bien même le ministère public ne
serait pas lié par une telle demande
cette mesure est tout à fait dérogatoire
au droit commun et c'est pourquoi nous
en demandons la suppression
merci chers collègues l'amendement
numéro 11 est présentée par monsieur
rapporteur au nom de la commission des
lois
oui cet amendement prévoit la
possibilité pour le jld le juge des
libertés et de la détention de
transformer une hospitalisation complète
en soit obligatoire dans le cadre d'un
recours de plein droit
ce sont les mêmes raisons que j'exposais
tout à l'heure concernant leurs cours
facultatif qui explique cet amendement
merci monsieur rapporteur l'amendement
de 460 rectifiée présentée par madame
escoffier et bien pour dire que nous
sommes pleinement en phase ou presque
avec l'amendement proposé excellemment
par notre rapporteur à une petite
différence près comme dans l'amendement
que j'ai défendue tout à l'heure le 458
simplement sur les délais et nous
préférerions effectivement à un effet
immédiat en précisant toutefois qu en
l'absence d'établissement d'un protocole
de soins dans les 24 heures les soins
sans consentement prendrait fin au lieu
des 48 heures merci chers collègues
l'amendement 263 tombe le 488 d'un
moment de cohérence sur à porter oui
monsieur le président donc amendement de
cohérence ne sentais pas la commission
l'amendement 21 se rapporte au nom de la
commission des lois
oui ça me permettra de me répéter un peu
ce que disait christiane demontès et
peut être d'une manière un peu
différente mais sur le fond je pense que
on n'est pas très éloigné cet amendement
donc 21 supprime une disposition
dérogatoire du droit commun le parquet
n'a pas à recevoir de requête d'une
autorité administrative pour demander à
ce que l'appel à l'encontre d'une
ordonnance du juge des libertés et de la
détention soit suspensif
quand bien même le ministère public ne
serait pas lié par une telle requête le
19 suppressions de mots inutiles le
caractère contradictoire du débat devant
le premier président de la cour d'appel
est déjà prévue par la référence à
l'article l 3213 11-12 tirer d'eux a
maintenant dix huit amendements de
clarification des amendements 20
l'amendement vin est un amendement
d'harmonisation de la procédure suivie
devant le premier président de la cour
d'appel avec celles applicables en
première instance devant le jld
l'amendement prévoit que le patient est
maintenue en hospitalisation complète
jusqu'à la décision du juge
sauf si l'autorité administrative décide
elle même d'y mettre fin dans les
conditions du droit commun et enfin
l'amendement 22 harmonisation de la
procédure suivie devant le premier
président de la cour d'appel avec celles
applicables en première instance devant
le jld mais si le cera porter alors les
avis de la commission un amendement sont
12 monsieur reporter la commission le
président a émis un avis favorable
néanmoins le rapporteur s'est permis de
penser que le juge des libertés est
spécialisé dans les questions relatives
aux libertés les logiques de lui confier
ce contentieux
plutôt que président du tribunal
des moyens nouveaux sons peut-il nous
sont apparus mon numéro 9
ce qui concerne amendements la
commission a émis un avis favorable
malgré les réserves du rapporteur qui
dit que est il vraiment dans l'office du
juge dont on est l'élaboration d'un
programme de soins
son rôle est de vérifier qu'une atteinte
excessive n'a pas été apportée aux
libertés l'amendement 114 alors
l'amendement 214 s'il s'agit de
permettre au juge de le substituer des
soins sans consentement en ambulatoire à
une hospitalisation complète
la commission a donné un avis favorable
malgré les réserves du rapporteur
merci l'amendement 458 rectifier il
s'agit de remettre au juge de substituer
des soins sans consentement en
ambulatoire à une hospitalisation
complète est là la commission a émis un
avis favorable malgré des réserves du
rapporteur
merci le 459 rectifier ce qui concerne
le 459 il s'agit de supprimer la
consultation du collège pour les
patients ayant séjourné en umd où ils y
ont fait l'objet d'une hospitalisation
d'office judiciaire la commission a
donné un avis favorable malgré l'avis
contraire du rapporteur mondement 121
l'amendement 121 il s'agit d'autoriser
le juge à procéder à toutes les
investigations qu'il estime utiles
bien que rapporteur et estimé que cet
amendement est inutile la commission a
donné un avis favorable le 400m le 123
favorable il s'agit de déplacer
certaines dispositions pour améliorer la
cohérence du texte la maman de 400
départs dont 124 1 alors là maintenant
la commission a émis un avis favorable
cet amendement fixe à 10
la période permettant l'application du
droit à l'oubli et améliore donc la
rédaction de ce texte
merci l'amendement 125 alors cet
amendement supprime la linea qui permet
aux médecins de préparer un programme de
soins si le juge ordonne la levée
d'hospitalisation bien que le rapporteur
et estimé que cet alinéa est nécessaire
et la commission a donné un avis
favorable à l'amendement
merci l'amendement 58 rectifier cet
amendement tend à prévoir la levée
immédiate de l'hospitalisation
lorsqu'elle est ordonnée par le juge l'a
malgré l'avis du rapporteur qui a
observé qu'il fallait permettre aux
psychiatres d'élaborer un programme de
soins la commission a donné un avis
favorable
merci l'amendement 440 132 il s'agit
d'une coordination avec un abonnement
précédent avis favorable aussi
présidente
l'amendement 135 coordination avis
favorable aussi monsieur le président
l'amendement 59
c'est à moi de m'en raccourci les deux
les donner aux juges pour statuer
lorsqu'il ordonne une expression
expertise
la commission a donné un avis favorable
malgré des réserves du rapporteur
merci l'amendement 62
le 62e je présenterai donc on semble si
vous le permettez monsieur le président
l'ensemble des avis sur plusieurs
amendements relatifs à l'audience
donc la commission a donné un avis
favorable aux amendements 60 238 465 466
14 rectifié 63 et 15 mai tous ces
amendements ne peuvent être adoptés
simultanément certains supprime purement
et simplement la visioconférence euh
pardon la visioconférence d'autres
prévoient des conditions pour son
utilisation
nous recommandons donc au sénat
d'adopter les amendements 14 rectifier
et 15 monsieur le serbe qui me
paraissent les plus complets 14 rectifié
vous avez 10 et 15 14 rectifié 15
nous en arrivons à l'amendement de l'iss
d'un avis favorable il s'agit d'une
clarification des règles relatives à
l'organisation de l'appel l'amendement
64 139 467 rectifié alors la commission
donné un avis défavorable
39 467 rectifié qui supprime le recours
suspensif ce concours est appelé à
servir que dans de très rares cas où il
apparaît que la sécurité des personnes
pourraient être mises en cause par une
décision de levée de l'hospitalisation
l'amendement numéro 11 l'amendement du
minerve
la commission a donné un avis favorable
à cet amendement qui permet au juge de
transformer lui-même une hospitalisation
temps plein en soins sans consentement
en ambulatoire
malgré les réserves du rapporteur qui
heures le programme de soins relève du
médecin l'amendement 460 rectifier la
commission a donné un avis favorable à
cet amendement qui permet au juge de
transformer lui même une hospitalisation
temps plein ont soins sans consentement
en ambulatoire
malgré les réserves du rapporteur qui
estime que ce n'est pas le rôle du juge
s'agissant de personnes n'ayant commis
aucune infraction
l'amendement 21
il s'agit alors la commission a émis un
avis favorable
il s'agit de supprimer la mention selon
laquelle le poker fait appel à la
demande du préfet ou du directeur de
l'établissement
la réduction de l'amendement et plus
respectueuse des principes du droit
l'amendement numéro 19 c'est un avis
favorable à cet amendement de
simplification le dit avis favorable à
cet amendement de clarification vent
cet amendement harmonise la procédure
d'appel avec celle suivie devant le jld
la commission a donné un avis favorable
et enfin l'amendement 22 c'est un avis
favorable à cet amendement qui harmonise
qui harmonise pardon lui aussi la
procédure suivait un appel avec celle
qui prévaut devant le
jl.d merci monsieur rapporteur madame la
ministre qu'elle est la ville du
gouvernement d'abord sur l'amendement ce
sont douze c'est un avis
enfin c'est une demande de retrait plus
exactement à défaut un avis défavorable
car la proposition n'apparaît pas
opportune juge des libertés de la
détention est compétent dans ce domaine
depuis sa création en 2000 et ce en
remplacement du président du tgi
il concentre entre ses mains l'examen
des affaires civiles et pénales mettant
en jeu le respect des libertés
individuelles garanties par l'article 66
de la constitution
le présent du tgi peut toujours en cas
de nécessité désigner un des vice
présidents du tribunal pour exercer les
fonctions du jld c'est pourquoi je
demande le retrait sinon un an
j'émettrais l'avis défavorable numéro 9
alors si vous le permettez j'associerai
ma réponse d'amendements ou pour une
réponse pour le moment 914 458 et 11
puisque un avis défavorable à ces quatre
amendements qui ont pour objet
finalement de donner au juge des
libertés la détention la possibilité de
substituer un soin en lui ambulatoires
sans consentement à la mesure
d'hospitalisation complète
en fait cette proposition mais le juge
en situation de devoir ordonné une
mesure dont il ne peut évaluer
conséquences notamment quant à
l'atteinte des libéraux liberté qui peut
en résulter
cet amendement c'est en est selon cet
amendement c'est en effet
postérieurement à la décision du juge
au terme d'un délai de 24 heures que le
protocole de soins est établi et cet
amendement reviendrait à confondre les
attributions du juge pénal et du juge
civil justive il n'a pas vocation à être
en charge du suivi des mesures médicales
qui relève de la seule compétence des
autorités sanitaires
merci le 459 rectifié alors
je dis oui j'ai associé à ce que faisait
donc je vais vous le permettez aux 481
ce oui oui absolument seul président qui
est un avis favorable du gouvernement
si nous en arrivons 123 alors je vais
associé à ma réponse si vous le
permettez le 124 le 132 et le 135 de
monsieur le maine c'est un avis
favorable du gouvernement donc favorable
nous passons car je rappelle que ce sont
des abonnements qui rappelle la durée
est là à partir de laquelle s'exerce le
droit à l'oubli qui est de 10 ans
minimum
nous sommes là pour avoir un débat
constructif n'est ce pas monsieur fisher
nous passons 486 le 486 alors c'est un
amendement qui vise à imposer pour les
patients en soins sans consentement sur
décision du préfet et ayant fait l'objet
d'une décision d'irresponsabilité pénale
ou ayant séjourné en unité pour malades
difficiles qu une seule expertise pour
permettre au juge des libertés de la
détention de statuer sur la levée de la
mesure
les dispositions actuelles prévoient
deux expertises mais dans le dispositif
à venir
le juge bénéficiera d'un avis
supplémentaire avec la vie du collège
cela apparaît suffisant dans un contexte
où les experts médicaux sont de plus en
plus sollicités et où il est parfois
difficile en d'en trouver convient de
rappeler que dès lors que le juge ne
s'estimerait pas suffisamment éclairée
de par ses prérogatives il pourrait
solliciter une autre expertise donc d'un
avis favorable le 124e elie favorable
nous passons 125,7 un avis
défavorable je crois que le délai doit
être maintenue parce qu'il doit
permettre médecins de revoir le patient
à sa sortie du bureau du juge de afin
d'organiser un programme de soins 58
rectifier le 58 c'est un avis
défavorable du gouvernement puisque
c'est un abonnement qui propose de poser
très général sont la caisse selon lequel
dès lors que le juge des libertés
ordonne une main levée et bien sa
décision prend effet immédiatement
non seulement il écarte toute prise en
compte de l'exigence de la continuité
des soins qui peut justifier un report
de quelques heures de l'effet de la
décision du juge ti un programme de son
être mises en place suite à la décision
judiciaire mais encore elle conduirait à
une incohérence avec des dispositifs des
dispositions pour rendre possible effet
suspensif de l'appel contre la décision
le dialogue mais 487 un avis favorable
merci donc sur le 132 à 135 donné un
avis favorable
oui nous passons donc aux 59 alors la
vie la vie c'est une demande de retrait
sinon un avis défavorable puisqu'il
s'agit ici de supprimer la possibilité
de prolonger le délai pour statuer du
juge ans qu'il décide de redonner leur
donne ans
une telle prolongation apparaît
indispensable pour permettre à l'expert
de disposer d'un temps minimal pour
mener ses travaux et rendre son rapport
en sur le 62e le 138 et le 465 rectifier
alors je vais associés ma réponse il
vous permettait monsieur le président ma
réponse aux 60 238 465 466 et 63 et
l'amendement 14 en fait l'amendement 14
qui a été présentée par monsieur lecerf
qui propose encadrer davantage de
recours à la visioconférence qui prévoit
déjà la nécessité d'une décision du juge
et l'absence d'opposition du patient
monsieur lecerf propose d'ajouter
l'exigence d'une attestation médicale
établissement que l'état mental de la
personne ne fait pas obstacle à ce
procédé technologique
le gouvernement est tout à fait
favorable à cette disposition qui permet
de prendre en compte la situation de
chaque patient et d'éviter les effets
néfastes sur la santé de celui ci la
visioconférence s'organisera au sein de
salle spécialement aménagée apparentés à
des lieux de justice est ouverte au
public dans l'hypothèse où ce procédé ne
pourra être utilisé vous prévoyez la
possibilité pour le juge de décider des
statuts et et d'ainsi tenir une audience
foraine cette proposition offre ainsi
une possibilité qui va objectivement
dans le sens de la protection de
l'intérêt des patients leur permettrant
de comparaître personnellement devant
leurs juges quand ils ne peuvent être
remplacé donc un avis défavorable pour
l'amendement 14 et donc un avis
défavorable pour les autres j'ai
mentionné donc défavorable pour le 62 le
138 dès le 4 165 rectifier les favoris
pour le 466 rectifié est défavorable
pour le 63
nous en arrivons donc à la mangue au 15
alors pour cet amendement je vais
demander à monsieur le cerf un retrait
sinon ce serait un avis défavorable
parce qu'ici monsieur le maire propose
que l'avocat du patient puisse être aux
côtés du patient et non auprès du
magistrat le principe même de la
présence de l'avocat n'est bien
évidemment pas contestable en revanche
le fait de ne pas permettre le cas que
le cas échéant l'avocat qui en pratique
sera le plus souvent celui de permanence
soit au côté du juge apparaît trop
rigide et source de difficultés il
convient de rappeler que l'avocat de
permanence et très souvent appelés à
intervenir
le même jour dans d'autres procédures
d'urgence bien évidemment dans les cas
où l'avocat ne pourrait être aux côtés
du patient la nécessaire confidentialité
sera assurée par le dispositif de
visioconférence afin de préparer au
mieux
l'audience merci
le 10 est favorable cette amende
précision caprins si vous le permettez
chez le 139 et 476 rectifié absolument
de ce président il s'agit si pour le
gouvernement d'émettre un avis
défavorable puisque ici on propose de
supprimer la possibilité pour le
ministère public d'assortir sa
déclaration d'appel d'une demande
d'effet suspensif
tout d'abord je dois rappeler que ce
dispositif existe déjà pour d'autres
décisions prises par le jld et qu'il a
été validée par le conseil
constitutionnel dans sa décision du 20
novembre 2003 le dispositif qui est
proposée par est donc particulièrement
équilibré en premier lieu le recours
suspensif et la loi est très claire sur
ce point l exception la règle est temps
que la décision du jld s'exécute dès sa
notification nonobstant l'appel qui
pourraient être formés en 2d dieu cette
exception est strictement encadrée
puisqu'elle est limitée aux cas d'un
risque grave d'atteinte à l'intégrité du
malade au d'autrui le 11 les donné un
avis défavorable nous en arrivons aux
460 triqueti fier intervenir sur le 11
mai je vous en prie madame ans je veux
des précisions à apporter parce que j'ai
entendu madame borvo cohen seat dire que
le procureur de la république décide
l'effet suspensif
or il s'agit bien d'une décision du juge
d'appel qui procède à cette décision
voilà donc le 460 rectifier le 467 un
avis défavorable du gouvernement
elle c'est une disposition qui est vrai
ni souhaitables pour des raisons déjà
exposée ni utile l'exigence comme je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure étant
d'assurer la continuité des soins à la
suite d'une décision de mme a levé le
488 d'un favorable à l'amendement de
cohérence
le 21 le 21 un avis défavorable
l'amendement supprime la précision selon
laquelle le procureur de la république
pouvait être saisi par requête du préfet
ou du directeur d'établissement d'une
demande tendant à obtenir obtenir
l'effet suspensif lorsqu'un appel à
l'encontre d'une décision de mise en
liberté et est interjeté en te en tant
que partie à la procédure
ces personnes sont bien placés pour
indiquer au ministère public ne sera pas
toujours présent à l'audience
les éléments permettant de fonder cette
demande au regard des critères exigés
par la loi
en outre une telle précision n'avait pas
pour effet de lier le procureur de la
république il n'est pas lié par une
telle demande conformément à la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
le 19
avis favorable le 18 coordination
favorable le vin favorable et enfin le
22 favorable merci madame ministre alors
nous reprenons donc l'amendement numéro
donc avis favorable de la commission
retrait ou défavorable du gouvernement
yat-il des demandes d'explications de
vote que ce pardon monsieur le cev
oui je voudrais exprimer les raisons
pour lesquelles je suis défavorable à
l'amendement 112
non seulement la commission des lois
souhaite que le contrôle soit
exclusivement confiée au jld déjà
compétents pour l'ensemble des
contentieux civil et pénal en matière de
privation de liberté mais elle souhaite
encore qu'il soit envisagé de doter ce
juge d'un statut plus protecteur dans
son avis adopté le 31 mars 2011 la
commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme a regretté que le jld
ne dispose pas d'un statut propre dans
la mesure où ce juge est un magistrat du
siège ayant rang de président de premier
vice président aux deux vice présidents
désigné par le président du tribunal de
grande instance qui dispose également du
pouvoir de le muter dans d'autres
fonctions
la vie ajoute que le jld est
régulièrement pointée du doigt
au gré de l'actualité est
particulièrement des cas de récidive
pénale
on peut légitimement craindre que cette
pression continue de tendent à remettre
en cause l'exercice en toute
indépendance de son pouvoir de contrôle
des mesures d'hospitalisation ce point
de vue mes chers collègues a également
été défendue lors des auditions par les
différents syndicats de magistrats c'est
pourquoi votre rapporteur pour avis
souhaite qu'il soit envisagé dans le
cadre de la réforme à venir de la
procédure pénale de doter le jld d'un
véritable statut qui passe par une
désignation par décret du président de
la république ainsi que par des
bonifications indiciaires qui tiendrait
compte des contraintes horaires auxquels
ils sont soumis
l'amendement proposé nous paraît aller à
l'encontre de cet objectif en prévoyant
que le jld serait un juge parmi d'autres
compétent en matière d'hospitalisation
sous contrainte
on pourrait alors imaginer que le
président du tgi ne lui confie pas ou
lui retire le contentieux de
l'hospitalisation sous contrainte en cas
de pressions exercées par la préfecture
l'établissement d'accueil
c'est au contraire à la création d'un
statut du jld qu'il convient selon la
commission des lois de réfléchir dans
les années à venir il se rapporte pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent par monsieur le
men only
il est retiré la ministre devrait
apporter une rectification parce que
j'ai émis 1 m
un avis qui étaient pas conformes dans
le dans le cheminement fait l'évolution
des amendes ans et il s'agit du 486 sur
le passage à un certificat médical pour
le jld
pardon pardon pardon oui voilà donc
c'est un avis défavorable à l'amendement
486 parce qu'aujourd'hui le préfet et le
juge des libertés bénéficient chacun de
deux expertises psychiatriques préalable
pour en donner la main levée de
l'hospitalisation d'office
je rappelle qu'on est dans le cadre de
deux malades irresponsable péno pour
pour troubles mentaux
en effet on comprendrait pas que le juge
soit moins bien renseigné que le préfet
sur l'état de santé du malade lorsqu'il
décide de prendre une telle décision
merci madame le ministre nous sommes
donc sur l'amendement numéro 9 de la vie
la commission favorable du gouvernement
défavorable pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien levé
la main merci que ceux qui sont contre
va bien levé la main alors je suis pas
sûr que vont nous reprenons un
l'amendement donc de monsieur lecerf fin
je rappelle que l'avis de la commission
est favorable
l'avis du gouvernement est défavorable
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement veuille bien levé la main
touche près de 14 15 16 chaînes
françaises
merci que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main il est adopté il est adopté
le 114 tombant de même que le 458 nous
en arrivons au 459 rectifié avis
favorable de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement veut bien levé la main merci
que ceux qui sont contre veut bien levé
la main l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 121 avis de la commission
favorable la vidéo pas de demandes
d'explications de vote même vote même
vote amendement 485 de la commission des
affaires sociales à vis du gouvernement
favorable
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veuille
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veut bien levé la main
l'amendement est adopté un amendement
123 avis favorable du gouvernement avis
favorable de la commission
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veuille
bien levé la main unanimité
je vous remercie
rebbie nous passons nous passons dans
l'enthousiasmé général au 486 jeu il est
retiré
monsieur à porter très bien nous en
arrivons donc aux 124 et aux 300 un avis
de la commission favorable à vis du
gouvernement favorable
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veuille
bien levé la main bien je crois voir une
unanimité merci amendement 125 avis de
la commission favorable à vis du
gouvernement défavorable ah oui il est
tombé il est tombé le 58 rectifié avis
de la commission favorable à vis du
gouvernement défavorable pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main merci il n'est
pas adopté l'amendement 487 présenté par
la commission des affaires sociales à
vis du gouvernement favorable
il est tombé amendement 132 avis
favorable de la commission avis
favorable du gouvernement
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veut
bien levé la main et bien c'est à
nouveau l'unanimité le 135 avis
favorable de la commission ali favorable
du gouvernement
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veut
bien levé la main merci unanimité le 59
à vif
avis favorable de la commission demande
de retrait ou défavorable du
gouvernement monsieur fisher et ils
retirer
non il est maintenu papa de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien levé
la main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main l'amendement
n'est pas adopté un amendement 60 238
476,5 rectifié avis favorable de la
commission avis défavorable du
gouvernement
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter
veuille bien levé la main merci que ceux
qui sont contre veuille bien levé la
main ils ne sont pas adoptées 466 serait
qualifiée même vote même vote le 14
rectifié avis favorable de la commission
avait favorable du gouvernement
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veuille
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veuille bien levé la main il
est adopté un amendement 63 tombe le 15
un avis favorable de la commission
demande de retrait ou défavorable du
gouvernement
oui monsieur rapporteur effectivement ce
je vais retirer cet amendement mais je
précise malgré tout que la situation
n'est pas une situation pleinement
satisfaisante puisque la plupart du
temps ce qui se passe d'après ce que
nous disent effectivement tous les jld
c'est que le président se retire une ou
deux minutes pour laisser effectivement
converser le le patient clients avec son
avocat dans des conditions qui sont des
conditions quand même extrêmement
rudimentaire ceci dit je suis
parfaitement conscient des difficultés
qu'induirait le vote de cet amendement
est donc au nom de la commission des
lois je choisi de le retirer
merci monsieur rapporteur l'amendement
numéro 17 tally favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement pas de
demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veuille
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veut bien levé la main il
est adopté l'amendement 64 139 et 467
j'ai donc été perdons pas de demandes
d'explications de vote non aussi m'a
d'abord reconnaît faire monsieur
précisant rapidement nous avons demandé
un soutien public parce que les
explications données par madame la
ministre ne sont pas satisfaisantes
puisque elle nous dit que c'est une
procédure qui sera forcément
exceptionnel je suis d'accord avec vous
que ces juges d'appel qui statue mais il
nous paraît que c'est une mise en cause
totale de des règles habituelles du
droit et donc et en plus c'est encore
une fois une suspicion à l'égard de du
jld donc de la justice judiciaire parce
que on voit pas pourquoi si vous voulez
le juge des libertés après deux
expertises alors ne serait pas en
capacité de statuer sur le maintien de
l'hospitalisation non donc voilà il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut et donc nous
proposer un scrutin public
merci chers collègues alors
effectivement j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par madame la
présidente du groupe crc spg sur les
amendements 64 139 et 467 rectifier je
vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront secrétaire un
bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre mais
trois bulletins bleus ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir métro un bulletin
rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
ce scrutin est ouvert résultat du
scrutin numéro 2 108 sur les amendements
numéro 64 139 et 467 rectifié l'article
premier du projet de loi
nombre de votants 338 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 337 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés 169 pour
l'adoption 150 2 contre 185 le sénat n'a
pas adopté
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance pour
la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
à suivre le magazine politique de la
rédaction de public c'est la preuve par
trois avec ce soir comme invité laurent
fabius ancien premier ministre
socialiste et député de seine-maritime
très belle soirée à tous